Film Courage: John we’ve known you for I
think ten years?
John Paul Rice, Producer: Yes.
Film Courage: Okay a long time and I know
you’ve come up with some great analogies
which I would love to go into later.
I know you talk about the Red Carpet Producer
which I still love that term…anyway.
But one thing I want to ask you about and
I heard you say it somewhere else you said
“Being in Hollywood and staying here for
a length of time will not maybe change you
but it will just make you more of what you
already are.”
Is that right?
John: Yes.
That was the advice that was given to me any
years ago before I moved out here by a person
who worked in Hollywood with Jerry Bruckheimer
and he said “John you want to take a really
good stock of yourself…here…now because
everything that you do here, because everything
that you think, everything that you believe,
everything that you indulge in (good or bad)
it will be available to you out here at a
much greater level and degree and things you
don’t even know about are abundant.”
And he said “You will become more of who
you are.
Rather than it changing you, you’ll actually
be able to fulfill all of those things that
are both inside of you and how you feel and
how you see the world and the kind of friends
that you hang out with and things you go and
do in your spare time."
And so I took that to heart.
I didn’t understand it other than in the
observable “Okay, he’s telling me to think
about myself and to think about who I am deeply.”
I wasn’t worried in that regard but in my
18 years out here I would say that that statement
is still very true today.
Not just for myself but for any of us.
I think it’s…Hollywood affords you a lot
of things (not just the film industry) but
Los Angeles it’s abundant.
It’s abundant everywhere you want to go.
There are several Starbucks within walking
distance, there are multiple places and things
that you can do and there’s also a variety
of people that maybe in your small town there
were only one or two there are now dozens
if not hundreds and a lot of them have money.
And taking that into perspective and looking
at these last several years of growth, it
can challenge you, too.
The only answer that I have for that is really
to look deeper within yourself and some of
those things that you have to look deeper
within can be painful.
They can cause you to feel disappointed about
when you don’t get what you want, that when
you create something that is not received
well, when you don’t win the approval of
certain people that you maybe want to work
with or have access to or get to “the next
level.”
But fundamentally I think what it teaches
you that discipline of introspection is one
where you become more fulfilled and happy
because of what you are actually doing that
is true to yourself as opposed to trying to
worry about what others outside expect of
you.
You have to start with your own internal expectations
and those things may evolve but they can only
evolve because of you.
Not because of someone else giving you an
opportunity or not or someone else approving
of you or not.
Ultimately at the end of the day how you feel
about yourself is the person that is up in
here and what’s in here.
And that personal commitment was the one that
I found in my journey to go through Hollywood
which is who is really…who am I?
Who am I truly inside and what do I really
believe about this world looking at things
with new eyes, being critical of myself, not
to the point where you put yourself down (I
think that’s an external issue) but really
one where you go Okay, what do I want to do
with my life?
What are the things that I believe about this
world?
Do I believe in the bad things about the world?
Do I also believe in the beauty of the world
and what holds it all together and how am
I going to grow up and how do I affect (through
art) what I see and know to be true and give
something to that that inspires how I feel
in me to others and so it comes from a personal
place where we all have journeys as artists,
we’re sensitive, we’re very open people
but I guess you could say that if you’re
going to use that sensitivity to tell stories
or say things, do it truthfully.
Do it through the vehicle of art and your
personal commitment is one that is an evolution
in yourself.
So what I knew ten years ago and what I know
today is very different but that doesn’t
mean that what I knew ten years ago was wrong
it’s just all I was able to do at the time
(what I was capable of).
And so drawing from those experiences, those
hardships, even the times where you feel really
down, you know maybe even depressed in some
cases, is not always at the time that you
see that as a real opportunity but it is in
those moments that you’re challenged the
most that shows you not only what you’re
capable of but what you’re also really good
at because you don’t have everything going
for you the way you expected it to or hoped
to or wanted it to and so you have to dig
deeper but if your digging deep is to blame
or attack or get frustrated and say these
people over here are causing me to…they
don’t know you.
They can do whatever they want to do but it’s
about yourself and the journey through that
process of booming your truest self is the
one that gives you the greatest success (at
least I believe that) because looking back
between where I started on ONE HOUR FANTASY
GIRL to now with a CHILD’S VOICE and six
movies later in ten years, I am so grateful
for that process because it had its ups and
downs and the only way that I can measure
it is that I’m happier than I ever have
been in my entire life and I want to keep
getting happier and I want to keep doing stories
that are not talked about.
I want to do things that help inspire the
good in people because it inspires the good
in me.
So the truest part of those statements about
people who…that it [Living in Hollywood]
doesn’t change you it’s really that you
do fulfill more of who you are if you allow
yourself to commit to that rather than trying
to chase after things and make it so that
somebody in Hollywood will “pay attention”
to your work.
But really go out there for the reason that
you want to touch audiences, you want to touch
people.
I also said something years ago that I didn’t
really understand at the time.
I think it was more of the digital world that
we were emerging in ten years ago after the
financial crash and how everything was going
digital and online.
Obviously it has played itself out quite well.
It’s still evolving but I said something
that Hollywood is not the audience, it never
has been and I would say that irregardless
of what Hollywood does as an industry in its
executives and all of those things I think
there really great people working in there.
And I have no doubt that there are people
who really want to make a different and do
good things in their work.
But at the same time, chasing after those
agendas and and modeling yourself after them
I think really in art you can become bold
and unique and different and stand out and
the only way I see people doing that is buy
commitment, full commitment to the belief
in what they’re doing such the point that
it’s not an issue for them about who’s
getting involved and not.
They’re determined to make the film at whatever
level they have to do it with the capacity
and the capabilities…they’re not waiting
on someone else to come in there and just
say “It’s okay.
We’ve got you.”
It’s really more so what’s up in here
and in here and trying to create that vision
and align people who feel the same way you
do and are joining you on this journey and
going through it because there is a commitment
from within them.
I think as a producer there is a responsibility
there to set that kind of tone which is not
an authoritarian one.
It’s one of your own self and attracting
those kind of people and that’s how we’ve
been able to do the movies that we’ve done
because we didn’t have big funders.
We did crowdsourced.
We did our own personal funds.
We brought other people into the mix that
were kind fo like silent investors.
They just wanted us to do well.
And I can’t wait for what we do next.
I really can’t.